okay let's try though all right I bet a
porcupine or was it an armadillo I don't
know who that is but they had to go
outside of y'all stop yelling why do you
think what can't you hold your liquor
and if actually I want to give you the
excuse of being drunk and then just
being a shitty obnoxious person oh I
hope you're drunk I have to see what I
was drunk
how does [ __ ] but I was drunk that
interrupt to show that eleven hundred
other people are watching grab drunk
I like to ruin one or two people's nuts
a cab driver a bartender a woman that
I'm seeing that I don't go on a big
venue that I like to work on a small
scale you serve by social terrorists
your social terrorist you have a bigger
needful attention than I do
this I worked at it and got on
television you just be in a darkness of
[ __ ] United I mean whatever parlay this
insanity [ __ ] but he gave me you kids
hang out in front of the video a that
was me yelling like a jackass what
happens to get some water we don't
don't yell man if you have a yes dick so
this is a thing man if you want
attention you have to do what I did and
work really hard for 13 years go by the
right Jake I don't why why Jay you know
that is and don't but watch it those
defending the rappers from Compton a
goofy white dude and he asked I had like
this on sir and a shitty t-shirt and he
smells weird
I'm about the Y J all right
this moves along
and I move along after I just I just I'm
fascinated with what Hackl is like the
just individuals like the psychology of
it what somebody's like I'm gonna pay
money to see you but also I'll try to
undermine you at any moment
[Music]